it was a momentous morning for students
learning the next chapter in their dream
to become doctors match day eight news
now's Brian will explains how this can
help with the doctor shortage we're
seeing here in Nevada
surrounded by friends family and fellow
classmates the soon-to-be graduate
students at the Kirk accordion school of
medicine learned where they would be
spending the next few years
students picked their name out of a
field of lollipops to find out where
they've been matched for The Residency
program to get their graduate medical
training it's their final stop before
becoming a doctor
number one program Vanderbilt her
anesthesiology for Anna's Jesuit it's a
day he wishes his father could have seen
it's definitely
Jeju with a mother and sister were by
his side celebrating his match at UC
Davis for neurology while these students
are still a few years from becoming
doctors Nevada needs to add more than
1500 doctors to the workforce to keep
Pace with the national average staying
here in Nevada can be difficult for
these students due to the lack of
federally funded residency positions I
always like to see them go to Great
programs they got to come back we need
doctors here and that's what we really
asked them to think about 39 of these
soon-to-be doctors matched locally with
the rest matching at prestigious
institutions across the country with the
hope that they'll come back here and
help fill the doctor shortage in Nevada
reporting in Las Vegas Brian will 8 News
Now
the students will continue their studies
for the next few months before
graduating in May